[Music]
so today we're going to talk about
creating a database with cloud sequel so
that's gonna be our first step is we're
gonna launch cloud sequel then we're
gonna move on to setting up kubernetes
we're gonna be using gke to launch our
cluster and then finally we're gonna
deploy an application on that and we're
gonna examine the fault tolerance of the
application so we're gonna take a look
at what makes it resilient some couple
of ways it can crash and how we can get
it back up as quickly as possible so my
name is Curtis van Gynt I'm a developer
programs engineer for Google I work on
cloud sequel so one of the things I do
is try and make cloud sequel more
friendly for developers it's pretty much
my whole job it's what I work on every
day but I want to hear a little bit
about you guys so I know we still have
some people coming in the room but I'm
just gonna go through each one and let's
try and get a show of hands so how many
people in here considered themselves a
developer go ahead and raise your hand
all right we got a ton of developers in
here that's great so how many people
consider themselves system admins ok a
few hands not very many how many of you
guys consider yourselves DevOps
practitioners ok great
quite a few hints and how many of
yourselves consider yourselves DBAs a
few hands how many of yourselves don't
really want to consider yourselves a DBA
but you do anyway
ok there's like five or six great that's
usually how these talks go so ok sweet
well that gives us a good starting point
I'm gonna try and introduce some of the
terminology so that if you haven't used
communities before you'll still be able
to follow along and keep up but we are
going to skip over some of the basics
like how containers work this is a 300
level course after all I don't want to
bore everybody else too badly
so so now for a really personal question
do you guys use tab they're spaces right
so why don't we get a show of hands for
tabs ok there's like a little over 1/2
little under half maybe a little under
half okay how about spaces ok it's like
40% of each and 20% just don't care so
so today our application is going to be
talking about launching the application
we're going to be launching is going to
be a voting system for tabs versus
spaces and so as you guys obviously care
very deeply about this we have some
specific goals of this we need to be
able to handle high traffic so when
everybody gets on there
the application has to be able to
respond I don't want anybody calling hey
voter fraud I couldn't get my vote four
spaces in so this doesn't count it needs
a little maintenance so I'm gonna be up
here talking I don't really have time to
monitor it so I need to make sure that
it's taking care of itself and it
doesn't really require a lot of hands on
for me and then I needed to be almost
always available if it goes down you
guys are gonna cry foul you're gonna say
the results aren't fair and we need to
make sure that that doesn't happen
so with that in mind let's let's take a
look at what we have for our database
we're gonna be starting with cloud
sequel today so if you haven't used
cloud sequel before there are some
really great benefits to using a managed
database the first of all is you don't
have to be a DBA anymore you can just
let Google take care of it
so it's fully managed we have Postgres
and my sequel instances and you can run
your air so you can deploy to any region
in the world that we support and it'll
work great you also get some advantages
like performance and scalability so
cloud sequel is optimized for our VM so
we take my sequel we take Postgres we
tune all the flags so that works as best
as possible running on our hardware and
you can also change the size of the
hardware with a few clicks of the button
so you can go from one instance to 64 if
you write it in half and it becomes
popular overnight you can scale your
database up if you are running a lot of
high-volume queries you need a little
bit of extra RAM instead of a little
extra CPU power so that those have
enough space to optimize those options
are all available for you and then last
but not least you get reliable
reliability and security so we've got
99.95 SLO surround availability and you
also get advantages like the high
availability options which we're going
to talk about in a second so high
availability is one of my favorite
features of cloud sequel specifically
for Postgres we have a really unique way
of implementing it how it works is we
have so in in GCP if you guys aren't
aware we have regions in them within
those we have fault tolerant zones so
zones are an entire zone can go down and
nothing will affect all the others
they're completely separate if you spin
up a cloud sequence you start with a
primary instance you're gonna click one
button to enable high availability and
you're gonna get a standby instance in a
second region so that's going to work
using our persistent disk that's a
service we offer it does storage level
synchronous replication so as soon as
your database writes in one zone it
automatically synched to the next zone
the advantage that this is you don't
have to worry about any replication leg
or anything like that as long as your
database accepted the transaction the
the backup is going to have it as well
so because of this we have the replica
waiting for you all we have to do is say
promote that one to master failover czar
very very quick typically take less than
60 seconds I if you guys want to check
it out we have a demo on the floor today
clouds high availability with cloud
sequel and the averages are somewhere
around 35 seconds so connecting the
cloud sequel when your database is in a
cloud there's always some interesting
problems you have to run to so cloud
sequel has a few different connection
options you pretty much have to choose
between two different groups you have to
choose one connection path and you have
to choose a way to authenticate so when
it comes to connecting with cloud sequel
we have public IP so that's an IP that's
open it on the Internet you will have to
pair it with authentication by default
it's is closed off you can only access
it if you're an approved user and we'll
go through how to do that in a second
and we also have private IP so private
networking is available if you're using
our VPC technology that allows you to
create a cluster market as VPC and then
all of the things inside that VPC talked
directly to each other they don't have
to go outside of Google's network
everything stays private everything
stays secure with authentication you've
got a couple of different options
most of these are used with public IP
but they definitely can be used with
private IP if you want that extra
security the first option is
whitelisting IP you can create a list of
IPS that are allowed to connect this is
an okay option but if any of you guys
are familiar with security there's a few
disadvantage to that so we offer some
other options as well you can have an
approved SSL certificate so you can
click a button get NASA self certificate
distribute the client key to your
application and link up with it or you
can use my favorite way which is the
cloud sequel proxy the cloud sequel
proxy has a bunch of advantages
including security and it gives you
control with an iam account so you can
actually create an iam account say
you're allowed to talk to this database
and then if for some reason you decide
that application should no longer have
access to this database you can either
remove that privilege or you can just
delete that account entirely and you'll
note there will no longer be able to
access your database which is great so
today we're going to be using the cloud
sequel proxy to connect so like I
mentioned it's really convenient you
don't have to worry about white listing
you don't have to worry about managing
SSL Keys all you do is create the iam
account
apply it to a service account and the
service account will connect on behalf
of your application this makes it really
quick really secure this proxy is also
open source it's available on github so
for some reason there's something with
the proxy that's not working for you
right you can download the code you can
compile it yourself make whatever edits
you need to okay so with all that in
mind let's go ahead and go through the
demo we're gonna take a second and
connect to cloud sequel so if we could
switch to the laptop alright so here
I've got a project created for us we're
just going to open this up go to the
cloud sequel page I've created a backup
just in case the demo gods aren't happy
with me today but we'll create a fresh
one well let's choose Postgres pick an
instance name and then I'm gonna use a
really secure password here alright so
you can choose any region you want so
this is the regions that we talked about
earlier and then you can pick any zone
I'm gonna go ahead and specify a zone
for no particular reason in fact we can
pick any of these zones and it's fine
you can choose your version we just
entered beta for Postgres 11 so if you
guys are interested in that you can
check it out we can set our connectivity
private IP public IP all of that we can
change the size so if we decide we want
a little bit bigger we can scale that up
we can even add extra RAM if we need to
or keep it pretty small for right now
and let's go down to high availability
so this is the high availability feature
we talked about this is gonna make sure
that we always have access to our data
with with no no involvement for me so
I'm gonna go ahead and look everything
over great I'm gonna go ahead and create
that ok so as you can see right now
what's happening is we're spinning up
the instance it usually takes like four
to five minutes to spin up a cloud
sequel instance so it's not very long
it's a lot faster than trying to install
Postgres yourself or at least when I try
to insult Postgres myself let's go ahead
and go back to the slides so while
that's going let's move on to the next
step and talk about kubernetes so how
many people have used kubernetes here
before
great quite a few people so at Google we
run everything in containers like as
much stuff as possible Gmail web apps
everything we can runs in the container
on our infrastructure even Google cloud
platform runs our VMs in containers so
whenever you spin up a compute instance
that's actually a container and we
launch several billion in containers per
week now obviously Google has a lot of
employees but not enough to hand manage
several billion containers a week that's
a lot of docker runs to type so we came
up with something called kubernetes so
kubernetes is actually based on
something we have internally it's open
source it's written and go and what it
does is it manages fleets of containers
so what that means is that you can
essentially just tell it what you want
your application to look like and
kubernetes will make it happen it is
based on our internal system which is
called Borg we took a lot of the stuff
we learned when we created Borg and we
we brought it to kubernetes it supports
multiple cloud environments you can run
this not just in DCP you can run it on
Prem you can run it on whatever cloud
you want and it supports multiple
container runtimes so you're not locked
into anything if you don't want to be so
if you aren't familiar with kubernetes
we're going to go through just a few
terms that we use specifically one of
them the first is when it comes to
kubernetes you have clusters so a
cluster is a group of nodes and there's
one master node so the master node
monitors the entire state of all the
other nodes and it updates the
environment as needed so it's going to
take a look it's going to say hey I'm
supposed to have three nodes here but
I'm missing one or something's not
working and it's going to work to
correct that so when we talk about node
we're talking about a single machine in
a cluster so we're gonna spin up a
cluster it's gonna have three nodes in
it and each node represents a VM or a
different machine that we're running on
and then last but not least we're going
to talk about pods so a pod is one or
more containers so a pot is an
atomically unit and kubernetes what it
is is it's an instance of your
application so you try to make the pot
as small as possible you represent one
runtime of your application and
sometimes you have multiple containers
which we'll talk about as well so if you
use google kubernetes engine there's
even a few more advantages so you have
auto repair' if one of your nodes goes
down so one of your VM stops working for
some reason whether it's something you
did it's something
the VM just crashed sometimes that
happens we keep an eye on it and we
automatically repair that and replace it
so your node could go down
we'll put a new node in your cluster and
you won't even notice we have Auto
upgrading so you don't have to worry
about running updates and stuff like
that you can just click a button and it
will automatically roll you up to the
most recent version of gke so if any of
you guys have ever tried to manage the
fleet of your own servers that is a
super time-saver
and last but not least we even have auto
scaling we're going to talk a little bit
about pod auto scaling but this is node
auto scaling so we can actually add
additional nodes into your cluster if
your cluster is not big enough to handle
the load you're trying to we can throw
in some extra vm's beefed it up for a
little while and then when the load
subsides we can take those VMs back away
and you only have to pay for what she
used okay so with all that in mind let's
go back to the presentation or the
computer here and set up a gke cluster
all right
so I'm gonna click right here to create
a cluster it's got a lot of the same
stuff we better just match numbers right
we don't to be wrong okay so we have a
couple of different location types we
can either have our cluster be in a zone
or we can have it be regional so what
happens when we select a region is we no
longer can select a zone but instead
it's gonna create nodes inside of each
of the different region sorry each
different zone so we're gonna have one
region but the nodes are going to be
spread throughout throughout the zone
and we can also be filles up a little
add some CPUs great so what's happening
here is I selected one for a number of
nodes but it's pers own so I'm gonna
have three nodes total and it's gonna be
spread out between the zones okay and if
any of you have ever tried to start up
kubernetes before this is a hundred
times faster than I've ever spun it up
on my own so I always love doing this
because it's very fast so while it's
spinning up those VMs will go back to
the sides a little bit and then we'll
come back and take a look at these in a
few minutes can we go back to the
presentation please great okay so let's
talk about deploying the application
let's take a look at the infrastructure
so we have a couple of different
components going on here it's a lot to
take in but let's break it apart so the
first thing we notice is we have the end
user the end user is going to be
interacting through a load balancer the
load balancer is going to be
distributing all of the traffic between
the pods so we talked about pods earlier
that's anatomical unit the pods are
incited deployment so we're gonna tell
kubernetes hey we have a deployment the
deployment is going to manage the pods
for us the load balancer is going to
direct traffic to all of the pods and
the pods are going to connect to our
cloud sequel instance and our cloud
sequel instance has high availability so
it's got a synchronous replication to a
standby instance if we take a look
inside the pods you can see we have two
different containers ones our
application and ones using the cloud
sequel proxy so this is what we call the
sidecar pattern so let's take a look
inside the application container so this
is a file from the actual deployment
you're gonna see it in a second when I
deploy it you'll notice we're using
secrets
so secrets are way that kubernetes can
represent information you create a
secret and it can interject those into
the pods as environment variables this
is a really good way to pass along
information so here we're passing in
information about the database user in
the database password you can also see
if you look on the top there we have the
container port so it's listening on 8080
this is just the default for flask and
you can see for image that's going to
pull a container image front right from
our my GC our repository we also have
the sidecar so this is the side cover
that goes audition to the main car and
you can see this is the cloud sequel
proxy this is an image we provide so you
don't have to make your own if you don't
want to you can if you want it's open
source you can just slap this on there
it'll pull it down and then you're just
going to give it the command to start so
we're specifying the instance name the
port we want the proxy to listen to and
then the credential file for the service
account that's all we have to do to get
it up and running we're using volume
mounts to pass this secret in so it's
mounting the file as a volume it's
putting that volume into the container
and the container is accessing it when
it starts up so then we talked about the
load bouncer the load balancer all we're
going to do is specify a name it's going
to be called tabs vs. spaces we specify
a type it the whole thing is called a
service we specify the type of service
the service is a load
and then the selector the selector is
going to determine which pods it's
pointing to so we're gonna be using app
tabs versus faces that says grab all of
the pods with the label tabs versus
spaces and start using those and then at
the end we were specifying what port
we're listening on now just because my
development server listens on 8080
doesn't mean we want to hear so I'm
gonna listen on port 80 I'm gonna send
that traffic to my pods which are
listening on port 8080 and with TCP okay
so now let's walk through deploying the
application and take a look at
everything we can switch back to the
presentation please so now that we have
these up let's go ahead and take a look
at what exactly we have going on so this
is the database that we just created you
can see here that we see CPU utilization
so this is an instance of the database
but we actually have to create the
database real quick on here you can do
things like you can manage connections
you can manage users all of that stuff
is provided here we've got backups
replications operations all that stuff
I'm just going to create a real quick
database for my application to connect
to and use ok so that is creating so now
I can come over here and do the same
thing with my gku cluster I can take a
look you can see the master version it
has an endpoint so this is the end point
that I would connect to the cluster
itself we have a whole bunch of other
other things in here there's a lot of
information that's all in here you can
take a look at any persistent volumes
any nodes all of that stuff is listed
here what I want to do is connect so I'm
gonna go ahead and click connect right
here it's going to give me a URL and I'm
gonna take this and move over to cloud
shell so if you guys haven't used cloud
shell before it's a really cool thing
that you get free with the GCP account
essentially what it is is the VM that's
it's not persistent you keep your home
folder but it launches up with a click
of a button so you can click it you can
open it up you can see right here I have
the application open in the background I
haven't deployed it yet but just to show
you guys the code it's very small it's
one Python file it is 175 lines of code
and most of that is comments so there's
not a lot going on there
it's just gonna connect to the database
for us and if we put this okay so that
is the command to connect we're gonna go
ahead and click that and it's going to
connect to our cluster everybody read
the text okay even in the back good
awesome all right okay so now I can talk
to you my cluster okay
maybe okay no resources sound that's
pretty expected let's take a look at the
services so we should see at least one
because kubernetes itself is a service
okay we've got one so we're connected to
our cluster everything's good so we
talked a little bit about secrets so
let's take a look at what the secrets
looks like we just have in here the
database name now these are encrypted
but you saw me intern earlier it's not
very hard in case you forgot it's one
two three four five these are just
encrypted you can either create these
via command line or you can 64-bit
encrypt it and throw it in here and
kubernetes will take care of it
automatically so I'm gonna do cube CTL
create is going to tell communities to
create the file and I want to start with
the secrets okay so there you go you can
see at the bottom I created two
different secrets one is the credential
file and the other one is the secrets
for connecting so that is the database
name password and username we can take a
look at the deployment so this is the
deployment that we talked about earlier
right just to go over it all again we
can see the name it's gonna apply labels
to everything in here this is going to
how our load balancer is going to find
it later for containers we have tabs
versus spaces we have the GCR i/o we
have our secrets put in here so it's
going to use those secrets this is the
side card right so I know it's hard to
see because it's not very big well it is
a big screen but it's not very big font
so so the only thing we need to do is
put the instance connection name in here
so if we come back to our database we
can go to the overview and the instance
connection name is right here so the
cool part of this is I don't even have
to worry about with the proxy I don't
have to worry about if I like
new database or sorry if I if I change
the IP address for some reason like if
I'm running private IP and I switch VP
sees the proxy will automatically figure
it out and update for me so I'm gonna go
ahead and create that right there okay
so I'm going to create to the deployment
alright so you can see the deployment is
now created
so if we try and find some pods again we
should hopefully see something ok so if
we take a look there we have one pod
that started up so that's our deployment
our deployment says hey I'm supposed to
have this application running it's
supposed to have a pod that pod has two
different containers in it so if we look
at the status it says it's container
creating usually the first time a
container creates it takes a little bit
longer because it's got to pull those
images from the repo but we can keep
updating this so make sure it's good to
go okay well we give that a second when
we're going to go ahead and go ahead and
start talking about the load balancer so
for the load balancer it's pretty simple
exactly what I had on the screen we're
using a selector app tabs versus spaces
so select all the pods with tabs versus
spaces and we're gonna listen on port 80
and we're gonna send that traffic to
port 8080
okay and that's all it took to create
the load balancer so it read that file
in it deployed it everything is good to
go so let's go back and see if our pods
are up and running okay you can see the
pod is running it's about a minute old
it has both the containers are up inside
and everything should be hopefully
working correctly we're about to find
out for real though so while that is
creating the load balancer let's come
back in here and look around so we
already showed you what the SQL instance
looks like you have CPU utilization
right now and not a lots going on we can
come over here to the communities engine
we can get out of this so we can see
workloads so right here we have a
deployment we have two tabs versus
spaces I can click it and take a look so
so far I don't have any CPU memory or
disk it hasn't been running long enough
but after a little while we should
hopefully start to see that kind of info
right perfect so here we have CPU memory
disk so you can actually monitor each
application and see what it looks like
we can look down we see labels this has
labels app tabs versus spaces that's how
our load balancer is going to find it we
can see down here these are revisions we
have managed pods so these are all the
pods and we have exposing as a service
so this is actually our load balancer
right here we can look at services - all
right we have an IP so let's click it
and make sure everything's working
awesome our applications up and running
so I'm gonna take this IP address I'm
gonna bring it over here okay now you
guys go ahead and pull out your phones
open up your laptop's whatever you need
go to that IP address make sure I'm
telling you the truth I'm not pulling
wool over your eyes and let's see if who
can win between tabs and spaces does
everybody got the IP ok anybody still
waiting ok so just to make sure let's
check on see how things are going ok it
looks like it's pretty close vote spaces
is barely pulling ahead good news for
the tabs folks I don't check to see if
you voted twice so just start clicking
all right so let's go ahead and go back
to the slide real quick
okay so now that we've deployed our
application let's look at some of the
things that can go wrong and what we can
do to stop that we've already done a lot
just by deploying with cloud sequel and
kubernetes but let's look at what else
can happen so when we talk about fault
tolerance it's important to remember
it's not fault proof right we don't want
to try and make sure that nothing can
ever go badly ever that is a losing
strategy you will never be able to make
that happen you're always going to have
some type of hardware failure or
something that's impossible to schedule
around what you can do is have a back-up
plan for handling failures so that if
something does go wrong you react
quickly and hopefully without a lot of
man-hours involved you don't want to
focus on eliminating the chance to go
down focus on getting back up as quickly
as possible so let's talk about
application failures now this is like
170 lines of Python I'm not very good at
Python so maybe I did something badly
and somebody figures out a way to make
it crash what's going to happen so
kubernetes is constantly monitoring this
it's going to take a look and say hey
wait a minute there's supposed to be a
pod running and it's supposed to have
this application in it I don't see any
pods it's gonna start that pod backup
within seconds I can go in I can kill a
pod kubernetes is gonna bring it right
back up high traffic so let's say that
my little pod was enough to handle all
of the 500 plus people in this room if
that were the case we have a feature we
can do we can add a pod autoscaler it's
going to add more pods as the CPU usage
increases so as more people begin to go
ahead and use the application kubernetes
is gonna go hey this one pod is not
keeping up I need to throw some more in
there I don't have to do anything it's
automatically gonna react it's gonna
scale up it's gonna handle that load for
me okay how about infrastructure
failures so now we've talked about a
bunch of things can go wrong on my end
what happens if an entire zone goes down
what happens if it wipes out I can't
talk to that node anymore I can't talk
to my cloud sequel instance well we made
a bunch of decisions earlier when we
decided to deploy regionally that even
if the zone goes down remember the zones
are fault tolerant in different ways so
if one goat zone goes down the others
are still remaining so our cloud sequel
instance is going to failover we're
gonna see it go down for maybe a minute
and it's gonna come back up and our
clouds are kubernetes instance is going
to do the same thing it's going to look
in the cluster and go whoa hold on a
second there's supposed to be a bunch of
pods running I don't see anything we
need to fix that
again hands off I don't have to do
anything so with that in mind let's take
a second and examine the fault tolerance
actually let's look at the vote real
quick and see okay somebody has
automated tabs and as you can clearly
see spaces is not going to catch up
anytime soon all right okay so if we
look we've got two pods running that pod
seems to be doing okay so far but we
have this load balancer here so what
exactly is this load balancer going to
do it's pretty simple it's going to
apply to all the labels where tabs
versus spaces is so it's going to look
at all the pods with Taz versus spaces
oh that's the load bouncer I want the
autoscaler sorry autoscaler so this is
horizontal pod autoscaler we have min
replicas right here so min replicas says
hey I want at least two pods running all
the time so what that means is that even
if something goes wrong in that pod
there may be like a split second where
kubernetes doesn't realize that pod is
down but as long as I have to even if
something goes wrong on one the other
one is still up and running so even if
we're waiting a couple seconds for a new
pod to come up and replace it I have
that one at least responding to requests
I can also set a max right so I want to
make sure I don't run two mini pods if I
only have three nodes too many pods
isn't gonna help me out either it's
gonna add a lot of overhead so I want to
limit that to 10 so only have 10 pods
anywhere between two and 10 is perfect
we can also look at the target CPU
utilization so this is how kubernetes is
deciding to scale this is a metric that
you can you can create your own metrics
kubernetes is really extensible this
essentially says hey I want each pod to
be at about 50 percent load that's going
to give me a little leeway just in case
the pod spikes up in traffic it's gonna
go hey this pods way over 50 percent I'm
going to throw some more pods in there
to balance it out and then we just have
some API stuff right at the bottom that
you don't really have to worry about
so with that in mind let's deploy my
auto balancer or my autoscaler okay so
now it's creating my autoscaler it takes
a little bit to start up I can check the
status of it with HPA so this shows my
HPA is the horizontal pod autoscaler
it's going to show its status right here
right now I'm unknown out of 50 percent
so it's still trying to initialize get
some things see what's going on we see
min pods - max pods 10 so let's look and
see if our pods have changed I still
only have one pod so the HPA is taking
its sweet time I see replicas 1 ok sweet
so now it started up a second pod it's
only 8 seconds old so it's still getting
there but we've got our backup pod in
case something goes wrong so even if I
were to crash one of these
yes that better is it is it still big
enough for everybody to read oh I see
sorry I totally misunderstood that
better all right thank you thank you
thank you I'll be here all day okay so I
deleted that pod and now you can't
really notice because I took too long to
figure out what your eyes were trying to
tell me but so it's hard to tell but
this pod was with the v6 and v8 and that
pot is no longer here so let me do this
one more time so if anybody's still
trying to vote which I'm sure the guy
who automated that tab script is he's
probably not saying any dropped
connections maybe one or two if he's
unlucky but as soon as that pod gets
dropped kubernetes realizes it stops
directing traffic to it and says it the
other way so if I go right back okay I
got two pods one is only 16 seconds old
so the one that I killed has already
been replaced so let's check again all
right tabs is really winning somebody on
spaces is trying to keep up but tabs
must just be better at automating the
votes so okay so we also have that
autoscaler so let me start up some
traffic so I've created compute instance
here I'm going to grab my IP address if
I can find it
I'm gonna grab the IP address and you
guys are just not quite enough load so
let's see what happened if we had
several thousand people trying to log
into this all at once okay so what this
is doing is it's just sending a ton of
requests it's using a tester called hey
it's written and go it's just sending a
ton of requests trying to max out that
as much as possible and we can even come
in here and monitor it so we can take a
look at our service tabs versus spaces
so you can see right now there's a sharp
up crease in CPU usage that's because
we're sending it a lot more traffic than
we were but so far we still just have
the two pods so okay so while that's
going we're also going to talk about the
database failover so it's going to take
like maybe thirty or forty seconds for
kubernetes to figure out that it needs
more pods the autoscaler is customizable
we're just using the default options
right now so it plays a little on the
safe side
we're going to switch the database and
there's a button right here for failover
so this is really useful if you want to
test how your application works you can
click failover it's going to simulate
that failover process so it's
essentially going to crash your database
intentionally your data will be fine but
it will allow your application to
practice failing over so we're gonna
click failover it wants to make sure I'm
really this crazy okay great so now the
application is failing and it's down so
if I take a look it's not working right
my it's sorry the application is working
but it's getting an error cuz it can't
connect to the database
so whoever is voting your app just or
your script just crashed and it's gonna
be down for a little bit it's gonna take
like 30 or 40 seconds and while we're
waiting for that to react let's go ahead
and here and really screw it up I'm
going to delete all of the pods
so unfortunately I don't have the power
to bring a zone down all on my own but
I'm going to delete all the pods because
it's a similar situation right I've
already shown you that I can delete a
pod and it's gonna come right back up
maybe okay perfect so now it's leading
all the pods you can actually see it
deleted four pods so the autoscaler was
working hard it kicked up some extra
pods and now it's deleted those so if I
take a look inside kubernetes if i
refresh this okay you see see here I
actually caught one of the pods that's
in the process of being switched out so
we have four healthy pods that have
already replaced the four that broke and
we have one that's crashed and running
and hopefully if we take a look over
here my databases back up and so is my
application so you guys were watching me
I wasn't doing anything could Randy's
took care of that all on its own with a
little help from cloud sequel on the
back end can we go back to the
presentation so that is examining
fault-tolerance we have about 15 minutes
left so I'm going to do some questions
at the end here if you guys are
interested in trying this yourself we
have a code lab that's available online
all the code for a similar application
you can create your own meme generator
if the only thing that's different
between tabs versus spaces it's making
memes so you can go to this link right
here github comm / Google cloud platform
/ G meme Jen it's a hands-on
step-by-step tutorial it does exactly
what I just did now so you can go home
and try it out yourself
[Music]